c'est ça mais il n'y a pas un jour y a
pas un jour dans mes messages privés sur
un stade que je lis je vous le dis je
les lis tous oui en ce moment j'ai pas
grand chose à faire et il n'y a pas un
jour on n'envoie pas photo ce mec
oui mais avec écrit gad elmaleh non mais
oui la belle halle à tulle en photo ont
fait savoir que comme ça chez des places
pour ce spectacle de gad sur wish c'est
lui qui vient et quand tu achètes aussi
parfois ses caves qui arrivent mais j'ai
survécu tout ça on n'est pas largué dans
cette jouissance a su après mes chansons
n'a pas parlé de la tenue de john
beaugard perso je dois servir et un gars
qui a demandé à trois personnes
différentes comment il doit s'habiller
ce soir ya une personne qui lui a dit
mais des baskets l'autre qui lui a dit
imagine tu joues me le donnes lauquet
dit il fait froid ne devrait rendre au
jeu trop salée samedi nos médailles
auront fait voler par un mec à les
chaussures de mickey
noah
cyril cet homme dans cet homme je ne
sais pas qui les met en tout cas sachent
que pendant pendant des mois et des mois
on m'a envoyé ce message et je me
demandais ce qu'il existait vraiment
quoi on le regarde
non seulement il existe
[Applaudissements]
bonne idée
c
mixez trouvent leur fais pas ça c'est un
filtre
[Rires]
merci d'être là ce soir c'est incroyable
vous êtes venus de belgique si oui alors
il est ce qu'on vous dit tout en bourse
semble à gad elmaleh est ce qu'on vous
parle de bus toute la journée comme unis
avec vous tout le temps mais ça c'était
céline ont saisi que toi ça serait serré
mais moi c'est une question pour vous
c'est que ce la faute et convoi qui a
été bouffé le quelques perles attend
derrière à bellamy pour garder c'est un
filtre cents par titre stable à regarder
abdelhamid ababsa soyez venus sur soi
merci abdelhamid vous avez un rêve où
les j'ai envie de le réaliser ce soir
alors vous avez comme rêve de chanter
avec gad elmaleh pour oiseaux ouais
ouais
est-ce qu'on peut ramener la paix
[Applaudissements]
medouar pour les femmes merci david je
t'aime sans réunir au midem et toi petit
oiseau pour abdelhamid c'est plus fort
que nous deux
toi aussi tu m'as balancé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
car
[Musique]
soysal sikkim ainsi qu'à voler
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les
tu peux m'appeler
[Musique]
et bien si tu peux marcher pas plus moi
aussi
il peut marcher
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mieux vaut mais ils ont même je
reversais mon ex se ramasser mon ex
j'ai relancé model s j'ai ramassé non m
je remercie
bon
au jeu
si je peux me permettre également de la
chanson le meilleur déjà ça s'arrête du
courage pour venir
il n'a pas capté que ça switcher sur la
chanson de camille lellouche il a
regardé gaz il a dit moi je la remercie
pas merci d'avoir été là ces a trop
entendu
[Applaudissements]